- You should definitely be
sampling both sides of the news.
If you're not looking at Fox News and CNN,
you don't know what's happening.
(electronic music)
- Hey, this is The Rubin Report,
and according to the paperwork
I'm still Dave Rubin.
Just a quick reminder, guys,
to subscribe to the channel
and click that bell over there.
YouTube's really been crushing
us on the recommended videos
so it's most likely the only way
you'll get to see our clips.
All right, then.
Joining me today is the creator
of the legendary Dilbert comic strip
and the author of the
new book "Loser Think".
Scott Adams, welcome
back to The Rubin Report.
- Thanks for having me.
- Third time, man.
- I say better every time.
- They say three times in the charm.
First off, before I ask you anything else,
because you're a man of persuasion,
how was my intro there
in terms of persuasion?
Do you think I persuaded people
to actually click the bell,
to actually subscribe?
Was I heavy-handed enough,
was I subtle enough?
- You might need a little technique.
You need to tell them there's a shortage,
all their friends are doing it,
everybody's talking about
it, you don't wanna miss it,
limited edition.
We might take that button
away if you don't click it,
and you might never be able to subscribe
if you don't do it right now.
Those are crazy examples but...
Yeah, there's probably another
level you could take that.
- There's probably another level.
- I should be hiring you
on retainer or something
to just deal with my YouTube problems,
and how to get people to subscribe,
and that sort of nonsense.
- I need another job.
(both chuckling)
- Somehow I really doubt
you need another job.
- I'm pretty busy right now with the book.
- All right, so, we're gonna
talk a lot about the book.
But for anyone that just
hasn't seen our interviews,
or for some reason has
never come across Dilbert,
or is not watching you
drink coffee on Twitter,
let's just do the Scott
Adams two-minute bio
of what got you into,
first, the cartoon strip,
and then now being an author,
and sort of a de facto leader
of the deplorables online, in a weird way.
- Wow.
I don't know if I signed up for that.
- How was that for a question?
- Where would you like me to start?
- Let's just recap the career quick,
for those that didn't see
the other two interviews.
- I was working in my
cubicle jobs for 16 years
when I was a younger man.
Those careers have a glass
ceiling, in both cases.
I can tell this story now.
I couldn't tell it at the time.
But in both cases, my boss
called me into the office
and said, "We got caught
"with no diversity in senior management,
"and so, until further notice,
"you're a white male,
we can't promote you."
They said it directly.
It's not an interpretation.
So after the second company told me that,
I left the first one for telling me that,
I went to the phone company.
They told me the same thing
after I was there for a while.
And I said, "I gotta find
a way to not have a boss."
And so, I tried a few things.
Cartooning was one of them.
Short story long,
I submitted materials to
the major syndications.
One liked it enough to say yes.
Cartooning begins,
that goes well, Dilbert.
And Dilbert turned out okay.
- [Dave] It did okay.
- I'd like to give the context
because it sounds like I went
right to it and hit gold.
But I tried other things.
I tried to be a programmer.
I tried to write, other things, et cetera.
This was just the thing that worked.
And then time goes by
and there's this President
Trump situation occurred,
first Candidate Trump.
And I was not intending to
make any kind of a pivot.
I just noticed he had some skills
that I thought I could
see that others couldn't
because I'm a trained hypnotist,
and I've been studying persuasion
in all of its various forms.
So when I saw him I thought,
"Well, it'd be useful
for the country to know
"that this isn't an accident
"that he's starting to get more attention.
"He knows how to do
this, it's a technique."
And so I started...
- Can I pause you there for one sec?
Because that's when I first met you.
You weren't even a Trump
supporter at the time.
You were just talking about
the techniques he was using
and just because of that, everyone said,
"Oh, Scott Adams is MAGA, he's far right,"
all of that nonsense.
Not that you were supporting
some of his policies necessarily,
but you were just saying,
"This is how he is doing these things.
"This is how he is gaining a following
"and getting his message out."
- I identify as left of Bernie.
- You still do now?
- I still do.
Because socially...
I can give you some examples,
but socially I do.
But what I eventually saw in Trump
is that he had a toolkit
that I thought could just do
stuff other people wouldn't do.
Take on China.
That's the toolkit you want.
Be the best cheerleader for the economy.
Literally get our psychology
working in the right direction.
Hey, everything's good, everything's good.
Why don't you invest?
Okay.
That's the psychology of the economy.
I thought nobody's gonna
do that as well as him.
And likewise, North Korea.
I thought, "Who could have a meeting,"
well before it happened.
I had already written about it.
I said, "Who could have a
meeting with Kim Jong-un
"and just turn this personal,
maybe find a way in?"
President Trump.
I'm a supporter in terms of his toolkit,
but that doesn't mean I agree
with everything he does.
- Yeah.
That's a hard place to
be in, though, right?
Because people don't really care
for that second part of that sentence.
- It's an expensive place to be.
And let me tell you,
because my income's down 30%.
There are just things I can't do
because I'm associated
with saying something
too nice about his skill.
- Can you talk about
that a little bit more?
What kind of business
things have dried up,
or even personal friends,
or I don't wanna say
specifically where you live,
but you do live in California.
I mean, you live in a place
that is maybe not so hospitable
to some of these ideas.
- Let's just say there
was a rebuilding period
where I had to make
new friends. (chuckles)
A lot of them.
- What phase of that building
process are you in right now?
- I'm living a very good life
with my girlfriend, Kristina,
and we're quite happy
with the way things are.
So I don't have a complaint there.
It's just an observation
that socially it became very difficult
to have the same friends.
- But what was that like?
Because I think everyone watching this
has been through that to some degree.
My book is about that.
It's about what happens
as you start sort of coming
out of the political closet
that you sort of get thrown under the bus
by people that you
thought were your friends.
Next thing you know,
there's this whole other
crew that's welcoming you.
I mean, it really is sort of a flip
on everything you know.
- Only my most, let's say, honest friends
were willing to say it to my face.
And that only happened a few times.
But mostly, I just noticed
that my Facebook feed
started to get...
(both chuckling)
It was getting emptier and emptier.
I'd be like, "Huh, really?
"Only one picture was posted all this week
"by everybody I know?
"That's weird."
And then you see that
they've unfriended you.
And then you check their feeds,
and you see what their
political leaning is.
You put two plus two
together, and here we are.
- Yeah.
How does your background
in persuasion, and magic,
and the cartoon, and everything,
fit your general demeanor?
I said to you right before we started that
you're one of the few
people that I now know
that when I see them on Twitter
I don't like them less.
There's so many people that I know that...
And we all are not necessarily
our best selves on Twitter,
and online in general.
But I see so many people that
I kind of respect, or I know,
and then I look at their Twitter.
I'm like, "Ooh, what is going on here?"
And I'm sure there's people
that say that about me too.
But you seem like you're pretty, like,
pretty much the same in both worlds.
- But to be fair, there
are a lot of people
who look at my Twitter and say,
"You're the worst person in the world.
"I used to like your comic,
"but now I can never laugh again."
Just in general, "I
can never laugh again."
- You've taken away their ability
not just to laugh at
you, but the whole thing.
- Have you noticed that humor
has just completely changed?
As been said, you can't make a movie,
a funny movie, a funny TV show.
In fact, if you watch
an old Family Guy rerun,
the whole time I'm sitting there thinking,
"You couldn't make that today."
- Couldn't do that one.
- You couldn't do that.
- But humor has become reality,
and politics, and it's very entertaining.
And thankfully we have
the funniest president
we've ever had.
(Dave chuckles)
- As a satirist, though,
what do you make of the
comedy side of this?
Because it's somebody like Seth MacFarlane
who created Family Guy, they've said,
I don't know that they're
going through with it
but I remember a few months
back they had said this thing
where they're not gonna
do any more gay jokes.
And it's like, well, the show
did 25 years of gay jokes,
and now gays are equal
so this might be the
time to make gay jokes
so you can further integrate
people into society.
That's what Don Rickles did, right?
It brought us all together.
Or The Simpsons.
They were gonna take out Apu for a while,
and then Hank Azaria,
the greatest voiceover actor of all time,
had to apologize for
doing an Indian accent.
What do you make of
not just the content,
but the people behind it?
The way they've been infected.
- I'm generally okay with the concept
that society moves forward
and things that we used to laugh at
we didn't realize were cruel.
And then maybe you grow up and say,
"Ah, that was really meaner
than it needed to be,"
or, "It wasn't really trying to do that."
And so I'm okay with society evolving.
But the trouble is it evolved away
all the things that were
the normal joke materials.
Now, it didn't affect me with Dilbert
because when you're in a family newspaper
there's a cap on what you can do.
So I was always well in the
family-friendly version,
talking about the workplace.
So it didn't affect me much,
but it certainly changed
the landscape of humor,
probably forever.
- Yeah.
Do you feel freer?
Because I think you said to
me last time you were here
that you've got some F-U money
so that you can be free
enough to do what you want.
- Yeah.
I didn't think it would
be as expensive as it was.
(both chuckling)
Maybe I woulda thought it through.
But no, it won't change my lifestyle.
And I did recognize that I
was in this unique position
where I had something to say
that, in my opinion, was not biased.
It was just, "Hey, this
is what I'm seeing.
"There's a little good and
there's a little bad here."
So I thought it was a unique niche.
Nitch, niche?
- I'll go with either one.
I'll take either one.
- I shouldn't say words
I never say out loud.
- I would have said niche, personally,
but I would accept nitch.
- As I look at your
lovely decorations here
I think that you're probably right.
(Dave chuckling)
- I'm better suited to figure
out the correct pronunciation.
- It feels like it fits
somehow, I don't know.
- What do you make of just how,
as a guy that you came out
of newspapers, as you said,
that now you use all of this
stuff in a different way?
You sit, in the morning...
Do you do it every morning?
You do it pretty much every morning.
You get on Twitter.
What, do you have your phone, just, like,
locked on something,
and you make yourself some coffee?
You just talk to the world.
That's a big transition from
putting a cartoon in the
paper and letting it be,
versus this fully interactive thing.
- Yeah, the difference is...
Yes, I do coffee with Scott Adams
on the Periscope app every day.
Then it moves over to YouTube
about an hour later, on replay.
But I started doing it
because I was just
interested in the election,
and there were people to talk
to, and I had more to say,
and I didn't feel like writing
it all down all the time,
because every day there'd be
three new things to talk about.
And then it just grew.
I wasn't...
I didn't really have no
expectation, no plan.
I wasn't planning to even monetize it.
It just grew into a thing.
And now, if I miss a day...
Because I do it on the
weekends too, holidays.
Because people are so addicted
to having the simultaneous
sip, as I call it.
So I do a toast of coffee with the public.
And that they miss it.
And so, now it's sort of a labor of love.
I would really, really miss it.
Like, this morning, my wife,
I wasn't working so well,
and I was like, "Ah, I don't
know if I could do it."
But I got my hotspot working,
and then it made me happy.
- You could have done it from here.
- That would've been great.
Most work doesn't make you happy.
You might like your job, but
it doesn't make you happy.
Whereas doing the Periscopes,
it's just a joy every day.
- I actually did it one morning.
I did coffee with Dave.
And I did fully credit
you with the coffee idea.
No one was talking with coffee before you.
But I did think that
there was something nice
about starting the day just
unloading a couple thoughts.
Just that in and of itself
I thought was refreshing.
- Yeah, and it has the
unintended consequence
that I often frame things
before people wake up.
So if there's something that happened,
say, in the afternoon,
the pundits and people haven't
had much time to deal with it
and sometimes I'm the
first person they hear
saying, "Well, the way to look at this is
"this is important, and this isn't."
And somewhat accidentally
I became influential.
- Do you think that's your primary skill,
a sort of framing of the craziness?
And we're obviously gonna get
to the book in a little bit,
but I think that's what you're doing,
is you're helping people frame
through just this endless
onslaught of information.
- I often say I have one superpower.
I've got one superpower
and then a bunch of supporting talents
that I've tried to piece
together over time.
The superpower is simplification.
I'm just a really good simplifier,
which is what makes one a cartoonist.
Cartoon is, by its definition,
the simplest thing you can
put in this little panel.
If you can simplify, you can frame.
Because it's taking in all the noise,
focusing on the thing that mattered.
So I naturally have that
skill as a simplifier.
- It's kind of funny, because
that's almost the reverse
of what everyone else is doing.
And this sort of is
what the book is about.
Everyone else is pretending
they know everything about
everything all day long.
People who can't tie their shoes
can tell you about climate change,
and the rest of it.
So it's like you're
doing the reverse of what
seemingly most of the blue
check Twitterati is up to.
- You should ignore anybody who has
a sense of complete certainty
about a complicated issue,
unless they're a surgeon,
and it's their domain.
But if it's just guy on Twitter
talking about climate change
or the, I don't know, trade with China,
they don't know.
- How do you figure out
who you can listen to
or make some sense out of,
or something like that?
- I just have a little of everybody.
I find the only way to
look in all the windows
is you've gotta figure out
what everybody's saying
and then maybe you've got
a little bit of an ability
to determine which one is more sensible,
sometimes not.
- Does the endless political part of this
kind of make you crazy?
In that everything is political now.
You talk about politics a lot,
pretty much every day.
But you don't strike me as, like,
a purely political creature.
- Well, my interest is actually
the psychological part of it.
I'm actually completely
uninterested in politics,
believe it or not,
even though I'm dealing with it every day.
I'm interested in the age of Trump
because of what that does to
our collective psychology.
And I think after he's out of office
I just don't know if I'd be interested.
It's not like I'm following
California politics
beyond the fires and the sidewalk poop.
- You think if things somehow reset
to something that felt more normal,
or at least closer to the
way things used to be,
two old guys, the way things
used to be, real boomers here,
you think that you might actually just
step away or something like that?
- I don't know that I could be interested.
If you imagine any one
of the Democrats winning,
I guess I'd be, you know,
super interested if it
were one of the socialists
because then I might have
to get involved as a citizen
just to do something
to stop what could be
a cataclysmic problem.
But other than that, no.
I just wouldn't be naturally interested.
- So what do you make about
what's going on with
the Democrats right now?
Because as I said, I
had you in originally,
before Trump was president,
just at the beginning.
And I think I said this to
you last time you were here,
the second time,
one of the reasons I was not surprised
at what happened at the election
was because I heard you.
And I was like, "I think
this guy's onto something."
So, if you were kind of right about that,
what do you make of the
split between the socialists
and then what I would
say are the last vestiges
of some sort of old school Democrat,
which is basically Biden limping along
and whoever else could sort of
be considered moderate there?
- Well, you know what's
really interesting?
I've never said this out loud
so this will be just for you.
- [Dave] You do know we're recording this.
- Shoot.
(both chuckling)
We're gonna find out for the first time
if the Democrats have kingmakers.
Because it looks like if
you left it to the public
they would pick Bernie
or Elizabeth Warren.
But anybody who's paying attention
knows they can't win in the general.
And they also want to win.
So if they have kingmakers
you're gonna see them emerge,
but maybe a little closer
to the nomination itself.
I don't know what that will look like.
And I don't know if they exist.
And do they exist?
Are there money people
who are just gonna say,
"Look, we gotta win,
"and these two candidates
aren't gonna get it done,
"so give us a Buttigieg,
give us a Tulsi Gabbard,
"give us a Klobuchar,
give us something else."
- Do you not sense that
that's what they tried to do last time
in that Bernie probably
had all the momentum
but they just cut him at the knees
and then felt that
Hillary was the right one?
So they already tried the kingmaker thing
and it would almost be too obvious now?
I think you're basically right.
That does seem like what's happening here.
They threw Biden in as
the firewall, right?
- I think Clinton was a special case
because I think she had her own support,
and that was pretty deep.
But will that support go...
How does it work when she's not in it?
What does that look like?
Are they still as active
to do something that would be Hillary-like
without a Hillary?
That's what we're gonna find out.
- So, basically you're
saying, if you're Trump,
you're going, "Oh, please
let it be Bernie or Warren,"
because you just think the
numbers-wise it's just like...
- Or Biden.
I throw him in there as the unelectable.
So top three are, by far,
the most unelectable in
the general election.
- Why Biden?
I get you on the Bernie, Elizabeth thing.
If people have just had
it with the woke thing
and the far left progressives,
believe me, I hear you.
But Biden at least seems like
he would maybe bring some of the people
that are just kind of fed up with Trump,
keep some of the centrists.
But you think then all the woke people
would just try to take him
out or something like that?
- Well, here's a question
I've been asking.
I've been asking people, even in public,
"Have you ever met a Biden supporter?"
(Dave laughing)
You're laughing because you
know you've never met one.
I've met a Warren supporter, a Biden.
You can go down the list.
But Buttigieg, haven't
met any, or Klobuchar.
But that's because she's low in the polls.
But Biden's at the top of the polls.
In fact, top of the polls even
in the general against Trump.
And I've never met one?
Or have I never met
one who would admit it?
- Well, I guess there's
a certain set of people
that are just deeply
unenthused who are just like,
"Well, it's better than that,"
so they don't run around with a Biden sign
or something like that.
- I have to think that
people who are supporting him
don't know who else is in the race,
and they also haven't seen
him on video recently.
I don't wanna be unkind.
When we first started seeing him
I actually said in public,
"Let's be kind about this,
"because this won't last long."
The party will take
care of it on their own
then we'll have a candidate
with full capability.
But I feel, honestly,
honestly, I feel bad for him.
- [Dave] Yeah, I do too.
- But at the same time,
I don't feel like I can
pull a punch anymore
if there's something
that needs to be said.
In the beginning I was gonna say,
"Just let this take care of itself.
"We don't need to pile on."
But now maybe we do.
Maybe we do need to pile on
if we see a real problem.
I just don't think he's got
the mental capacity,
especially if you fast forward four years,
or God help us, eight years.
What would he be in eight years?
- Well, it's ironic, because
I think a lot of people,
and obviously you would
not be a Biden supporter,
but you are trying to respectful of a guy
just as a human being.
But it does seem like
something is degrading there.
It just does.
- He's not only a human being,
but he's been a great
servant of the public.
He's apparently well liked on both sides.
I have a lot of good to say about him,
but it's just not his time.
- Do you think we're all
too focused on politics?
As a guy that's not a pure political beast
but is framing it for a lot of people.
- I wonder how many are focused.
You know, if you walked
down in the sidewalk
and you sat down, "Name our few
people running for president
"on the Democrat side,"
how many could they even name?
I don't know.
Could they find Ukraine on
the map, to use that example?
- [Dave] (chuckles) No.
That I know they can't.
- I feel like you and I,
we're living in this Twitterverse
where it seems like it's
the most important thing,
but maybe it's not.
- Does that, do you think,
sometimes make it a little harder
to judge what's actually going on?
Before 2016 it was like, because
we existed in that world,
we could see something that
other people couldn't see.
Now that world has sort of collided
with mainstream in a bigger way
so it does make it harder to
track some of these things.
Does that make sense?
- Well, I think it's
hard for all of us to see
outside of our bubble.
- That's what we're gonna talk about.
- And so I don't imagine
that I'm free from that.
The best I can do is
use some technique to try to see
the other levels as best I can.
So putting the effort in
is the best you can do.
You just can't tell if you're
seeing the whole field.
That's the trouble.
- Speaking of the bubble,
let's move it to the book.
First off, the top title is "Loser Think".
We'll get to the subtitle in just a sec.
But when you're titling the book,
were you afraid to go, "If I
call this thing 'Loser Think',
"the average guy..."
As you know because I
just wrote this thing,
and we're dealing with
titles and all of this stuff.
It's like you want them to
see it and be able to grab it.
But did you think, "Uh oh.
"If we put this out there
and it says 'Loser Think'
"people are gonna be afraid
"because they think if
they're gonna touch it
"that means they're a loser,"
or something like that?
What's the persuasion level
you were working with?
- Yes, we thought about it.
Here's...
I'll just talk you through,
here's how we thought about it.
Number one, I said, if
I give it this title
will people ask me, "Why'd
you give it this title?
"Isn't that a mistake?"
(Dave laughing)
Bingo, bingo.
Everybody asked me that.
- I just fell right into the trap.
- No, and that was anticipated
that people would wonder that.
Two, because there exists
the Dummies series of books
and the Idiot's Guide,
it's been proven that
people will buy a book
that says they're an idiot on it.
And lots of them.
(Dave laughing)
These are two...
The series, the Dummies
and the Idiot's Guide books
are enormous, so clearly that.
But here's the other insight
I had because of Dilbert.
When I wrote Dilbert it was, of course,
making fun of your boss, most of the time.
But bosses kept buying my material.
And I would be like, "Why are
you buying it," in my head.
And they would say, "This
perfectly describes my bosses."
- [Dave] Right, right,
right, even the bosses.
- Nobody thought it was them.
So we're primed to think
this is about someone else.
I believe most people are
picking this up and saying
one of two things.
They're saying, "Ha ha, this will be fun.
"We'll mock all those people."
And it does,
if they wanna see
unproductive thinking
techniques in the book.
And two, this will be a perfect
gift for my brother-in-law,
(both laughing)
and it'll be a private
joke that that's the title.
- Right, so, the subtitle is,
"How Untrained Brains
Are Ruining America".
Now that makes a lot of sense to me
because that seems like pretty much
everything that's
happening at every level.
At academia, at the political
level, at the media level.
Do you mean it at every
level, just across the board?
- Well, it's certainly
making everything worse.
And the problem is that everybody thinks
they have this thing called common sense.
And therefore they think they're arguing
about politics or priorities or something.
And often, they're not.
They're just unproductively thinking
so that the thing they're
saying is actually nonsense.
It's not an opinion, it's not a priority.
It's just sort of nonsense
because they don't know
how to productively think.
So I thought, "Well, I'll
try to make it accessible."
Instead of writing a how to
do logic book kinda book,
which nobody's gonna read,
I'll just give you the
friendly anecdote version
that you could absorb pretty easily.
- All right, so, if you're
trapped in your bubble
and it's becoming a
self-fulfilling prophecy,
what's the first step to
breaking out of your loser think?
- Well, it's good to
know what all the various
parts of loser think are.
And I go through them.
Like don't be a mind reader.
Don't predict the future with analogies.
History doesn't predict.
Slippery slope isn't real.
Fairness...
- I wanna go through a few of those.
- Without details, it's
good to know what those are.
But beyond that, you should definitely
be sampling both sides of the news.
If you're not looking at Fox News and CNN,
you don't know what's happening.
Because I've tried doing that.
Pick a topic, and before you've
heard what the other says,
just consume one silo.
And then you go to the other one.
You're like, "What?
"I didn't know anybody was saying this.
"Are you telling me these facts are real?"
And it doesn't matter
which way you're going.
They're completely different.
- But is it almost impossible
to break out of that?
I mean, we all talk
about this all the time.
We're catering news to ourselves.
The algorithms are feeding us things
that reinforce our thoughts already.
But is it almost impossible
to break out of it
because in a weird way, psychologically,
we don't wanna break out of it?
I know some people do,
but that most of us, kinda, we just...
Does it not sound corny?
That's the safe space
we find, and we're good,
and we're reinforced, and it's warm.
- This is why I sneak in the back door.
If I said to you, "Dave, I'm
gonna get you to change teams,"
whatever your team is,
Democrat, Republican, doesn't matter,
you would immediately
say (imitates screeching)
Or you'd be like, everything
you're shooting at me
is bouncing off my force field.
But if I say, "Here's
how you should think.
"In any situation,
"you wanna have something
to compare something to,"
a very simple statement,
people accept that
because that's just
reasonable on its surface.
And then you take that through,
all right, now apply
this to your thinking.
So you can sometimes get people
to talk themselves out of their position
by giving them better tools.
But you can't just say,
"Change teams because
you're on the wrong team."
- How much of this do you think
is just base human psychology?
Just the stuff we're born with.
That certain people are
just more programmed
to go to just things that
reinforce their beliefs,
and some people are just programmed
to actually being a little bit more open?
- Well, I think all of these things,
you're born with a certain set
of gifts and intelligence, et cetera.
But in "Loser Think" I talk about how
the experience you've had across domains
is what gives you better vision.
For example, if you'd never
been exposed to economics,
I've got a degree in economics,
you wouldn't know how economists think.
So you might run into a
concept like a sunk cost.
And if you'd never been exposed to this
you might say, "Well,
I have common sense."
And people would say, "We've
already spent all this money
"so we better keep investing
"because I don't wanna waste
that money I already spent."
That's not sensible.
An economist would say, "No.
"The money that's gone
"should not influence your next decision,
"because it's gone."
Now, the first time you hear
that, you say, "Oh, yeah."
Like, you don't need to read a
book on it. You just hear it.
And so I tried to make
it as simple as that.
You just gotta hear it once, and you say,
"Ah, yeah, that makes sense."
- You think we all have
preprogrammed abilities
to be flexible on some of these things,
but you think that that can
pretty much always be...
- Different levels.
I mean, people are more or less locked in,
more or less team players,
more or less capable of looking at details
and thinking properly.
But everybody can do it better.
- Do you think the
internet's changing that,
just relative to the speed
that we get information,
and the fact that you can
now go out there and find
roughly a gajillion voices in two minutes
that might be able to help
break some of your stuff?
- I'll tell you, the
biggest problem, I think,
and this is a brand new thought,
is that we are, as humans, we're copiers,
we're imitators.
So if you wade into the internet,
what kind of thinking
style are you gonna see?
The worst.
And people will imitate it.
So they'll say, for example,
"Hey, your side did X."
And what's the most common response?
Your side did X.
What did that help?
That helped nothing.
That wasn't even on the topic.
You didn't even talk about your topic.
- But if they're gonna
do it, we have to do it.
- So some of it is, of
course, power, and influence,
and persuasion and all that.
Nobody's trying to think.
You have to be able to weed out,
okay, was anybody even trying,
or were they just persuading?
- Do you think most of us
just don't wanna try, though,
at some level?
I mean, most people just kinda...
They don't wanna think
about things that seriously
because that brings up a
lotta deep existential stuff.
- Yeah, maybe, maybe.
There are lots of reasons.
We don't wanna be wrong.
We don't like to be embarrassed.
We don't like to change our mind.
We don't wanna disappoint the team.
And we're influenced by what we see,
so we just join in and say,
"Well, that's what my team's doing.
"I guess I'll do some of that."
- You talk about
some of the dumb ideas
that are floating around,
that thus create our own bubbles.
I wanted to go through a couple of them.
Because we hear these all the time,
and they sorta sound right
but you don't quite think they are right.
- We know when history will repeat itself,
and when it won't.
We hear this all the time.
- History repeats.
- Yes, history repeats itself.
- And because it has a phrase,
and we've heard the phrase,
we give it weight.
Because the brain will
say, "Well, it's a saying.
"I'm pretty sure I've seen
that on a bumper sticker
"so there must be something about that."
But it's an illusion caused by the fact
that we don't notice when
history doesn't repeat,
which is most of the time.
And why is it that history doesn't repeat?
Because it can't.
There's never two situations
that are the same.
The variables are changed.
And if nothing else has changed,
you saw what went wrong the last time,
so you fix it this time.
It's a complete illusion that
we can predict the future
because this time is like that last time.
The most you can do is say
people are still selfish,
stupid, and all those things.
So if you put them in a
situation where they can steal,
well, sure, they'll steal.
And not everybody,
but if you have enough people
introduced to a situation
where you can steal something,
somebody's gonna take a run at it.
But that's not really history repeating.
- Right, so you would say
a better way to say it
would be something like,
themes repeat themselves,
just because it's based in our nature,
not the specific event?
- I would even make it smaller than that.
I would say people are people.
You know they're gonna be selfish
and all the qualities of people,
so any situation you put them in
you should say, "Well, let's
look at cause and effect."
If I put that person
where the free money is,
I should expect money to be taken,
but not because history repeats.
There's just a simple cause and effect.
- So if it doesn't repeat itself,
what would you say to all
the history majors right now
that are listening to this?
What would be the point
of being a historian
if not to have some sort
of roadmap for the future?
- Well, indeed, history is what
prevents it from repeating, in some sense,
because you know what didn't work.
So you might see history
repeat when it works.
If something worked before
you might see somebody
try to try it again.
But even you take
anything, like North Korea.
What was the main thing people said
when President Trump got elected?
It was, "Well, talking to North Korea
"will never work," blah blah blah.
And maybe it won't.
But he got it further than anybody else.
He got it into a personal level.
It wasn't anything like history.
So no matter how many
times history had repeated,
you introduce this whole new
variable of President Trump
and then history doesn't count anymore.
- What do you make of that concept,
that people who said
one thing two years ago
say the complete opposite?
I don't mean that they've
flipped all of their beliefs,
but that it's always a team thing.
It's like, if Obama had talked to...
Gone to North Korea and
talked to Kim Jong-un,
a certain set of people, the
Republicans in this case,
would have been like, "He's crazy.
"We can't talk to these people."
If Trump does it, we can do it.
You can flip that the other way.
I guess that goes to what you're saying
about the team thing.
But do you think people realize
the sort of absurdity?
I'm not talking about
evolving over a period of time
with a certain set of opinions.
I'm talking about because
the players are different
that you just completely
take an opposite side.
- One of the great mysteries is
you watch somebody who
doesn't agree with you,
and they're doing that crazy
thinking like you mentioned.
And you watch them, and
you think to yourself,
"Is that real?
(Dave laughing)
"Do they really think that?"
And I spend time doing that too.
But one of the advantages I have is,
having studied hypnosis,
I understand people to be
irrational most of the time.
And I understand them to be rationalizers,
and I understand confirmation
bias and cognitive dissonance.
So my take is that most of the time
they actually believe what they're saying,
because they can't see it.
They're the ones who are blinded to it
so that it looks like
it makes sense to them.
- Do you think there's some reason,
like an obvious psychological reason
that the people who seem most obsessed
by politics on a day-to-day basis,
and I'm not talking
the broad-themed stuff,
but as you said before,
you're really uninterested in politics.
But the people that are obsessed
with the nitty gritty...
(clears throat) Excuse me.
The nitty gritty what happened today,
what happened tomorrow, or
what's happening tomorrow,
there's a reason that
they're so miserable.
Because it's sort of...
It's like an untenable system
that they're playing with all the time.
- Well, you know,
people are different so it's
probably all different reasons.
I do it for entertainment.
And I think other people
are drawn in for the fight.
They like the fight.
What's my fight today?
Ooh, there's a new headline.
Let me get into that fight.
There's definitely a, I don't know,
dopamine or serotonin hit that people get
just from making a good point.
It's like, "Ah, got that guy
"who said something bad
about this celebrity.
"Ah, got him."
- Got him.
Somehow I think if this was a real fight,
like involving weapons, they
would be much more reserved.
What do you think?
- I know I would.
(both chuckling)
- Yeah, exactly.
Okay, let's plow through
a couple of these others.
This is a good one
because we hear some version
of this all the time online.
We can tell the difference
between evidence and coincidences.
- Yeah.
We go through our life
thinking that things matter.
Let me give a perfect example.
If you were a fiction writer
and you were writing a book,
or even reading a book,
and somebody put on a watch,
you'd say to yourself,
"Oh, later, that watch..."
- [Dave] Something's
going on with the watch.
- Pay attention to the watch
because the author
included that for a reason.
So it's easy for some people
to have some experiences
to imagine everything's connected.
Musicians, poets, artists,
they imagine a connected world
because that's what they live in.
Whereas the economist,
the scientist, the lawyer,
if they're not advocating,
would say, "Oh, you've
gotta look at these.
"You've gotta look at all
these coincidence individually
"and say, 'All right, is this
real, or just a coincidence?'"
We're creatures who think
coincidence matters.
And if we don't really police ourselves
we create a bubble by imagining
our little coincidences are meaningful.
I give one example in the book.
I was walking home one day,
and I had bought some Sharpies,
because I like them for
a variety of reasons.
I took it out of my bag,
literally was holding in my hand,
and Fox News was on, and Greg
Gutfeld was on, on his show.
And he says, "I love Sharpies.
"I really want Sharpies."
I'm like, seriously?
While it's in my hand.
And how many times have
you seen a TV show...
- But Scott, there are no
coincidence, I thought?
What could this mean?
So you're saying that's not
the universe talking to you.
Because we've all had that moment.
And you go, "Whoa, that has some meaning."
But the way, I've been on
Gutfeld's show many times.
He loves Sharpies.
- He does.
- He's got a whole thing of Sharpies.
There's Sharpies in all his drawers.
They're just filled up with Sharpies.
- He and I could have a club
of just people who love Sharpies.
- But do you think truly that there's...
Do you think there's no chance
that there's meaning
in that sort of thing?
Like, I know the Sharpie
example is kind of simple.
But, you know, you're having
some deep, deep thought,
and you're watching TV
and then suddenly a character
says exactly what you're
thinking. Now, I get it, I get it.
You're just talking about
sort of law of averages also.
Like, every now and again
this is gonna happen.
You're never gonna notice the
ones when it doesn't happen,
which is all day long.
I get that.
But do you think that there's
no meaning or value to that?
- Well, not the examples that we gave.
There are no meanings to those,
unless we're a simulation,
and we're software,
and there's a little code reuse going on.
- Maybe we'll end with that.
- Can't rule that out.
- Let's end with the simulation stuff.
Let's stay with the book for now,
but we'll go to simulation at the end.
- Short of that,
it can mean something
in a criminal situation.
If somebody gets killed,
and their spouse has booked
a flight out that morning,
(both chuckling)
and they didn't pack a bag,
maybe that means something.
So certainly in a political context...
I'm sorry, the legal context,
you have to track them down.
- What about just in a personal context?
Like if you find meaning in something
that may be purely coincidental,
or however else you wanna describe it,
ridiculous, or whatever.
But if you personally
find some meaning in it.
- Here's my advice.
We're bombarded with
coincidences all the time.
When they work in your
favor you should say that,
"Well, that means something.
"That means I should write this book.
"That's telling me that I'm
gonna get a check in the mail."
And if it looks a coincidence
that's telling you
something bad's gonna happen
you say, "Pfft, coincidence."
- All right, seems fair enough.
The simplest explanation is usually true.
- People like to win arguments by saying,
"Yours is complicated, but
mine's the simple one."
And the problem is,
first of all, the world
sometimes is complicated.
Pick any major thing in the
news, it's pretty complicated.
But the real problem is that we all think
our explanation is the simple one.
That's where the cognitive
problem comes in.
My example I use is, "How
did the world get here?"
Well, ask the creationist.
God did it.
You can't get any simpler than that.
Ask the scientist who's the evolutionist,
"How did it all get here?"
Gradual change.
Big Bang, simple.
Which one is the simple one?
Well, everybody thinks their
explanation is the simple one.
Especially the one-variable people
who will look at a
complicated thing and say,
"Well, one variable, got it.
"Simple, it's that one variable."
- So which was it, God or Big Bang?
- Simulation.
(both laughing)
- Again, we're gonna...
I do wanna do...
- Try to keep that away from
me. You can't, you can't.
- We will end with simulation then.
But sometimes we need some simple answers
in a complex world, do you think?
- Well, it helps if you can simplify,
but you don't wanna oversimplify.
And then how do you know, how do you know?
So every situation is
a little bit different.
But certainly, if you're looking at,
let's say, climate change,
I don't wanna get into that in any detail,
but to just say...
I'm shaking my head because I
can barely say this out loud.
One of the things I hear
the most from the skeptics
is that the scientists forgot
to account for the sun.
(chuckles) The sun.
- Wait, they claim that the
scientists forgot about the sun?
- That they didn't
account for solar flares
or solar activity.
And I always say the same
thing, which is, all right.
It's your job to figure
out why the Earth is warm.
You thought of the sun.
- [Dave] The sun might be in there.
- You might have gotten something wrong,
but it wasn't because
you didn't look at it.
You thought of the sun.
So come up with a better skepticism.
Skepticism is fine.
But if you simplify it into,
"I think they forgot to look at the sun,"
you're not helping.
- It's funny you bring up
climate change, though.
Without going too far
down that rabbit hole,
it reminds me of something
like the Paris Accords,
first when they got signed
and then when they got retracted,
or whatever you wanna call it, by Trump.
It was like, all of these
people, it all sounds good.
We're gonna cut these emissions.
We're gonna do this, we'll pay for this.
It all sounds good in a simple sense,
if you don't think about it.
And then we are now out of the Accords.
From what I understand,
we're actually exceeding
many of the limitations
that were originally signed.
And there was no mechanism
to force anyone to actually do anything.
It was literally just a piece of paper.
But all these people
were screaming about it
like it was the end of the world.
And we see this with net neutrality.
It was the end of the world.
Is your internet still working?
- Barely.
(Dave laughing)
- Oh, right, you had a
Wi-Fi problem this morning.
But that, basically, we
go from end to the world,
to end of the world, to end
of the world situations.
- Yeah.
We're locked into whatever's
the scariest thing.
What's the scariest thing?
With the example of the
Paris Climate Accord,
if you have, let's say, more
experience in this world,
probably nothing gets
solved with a meeting.
(both chuckling)
And we had an agreement,
and then everybody kept it.
That's not the real world.
And I think--
- But that just makes a lot
of people feel good, right?
When I've mentioned this
and then people confront me about it,
and then I say to them,
"Well, what was in it,"
or was any country, actually,
was there any mechanism to
force countries to abide by it?
Or what has happened since we got out?
I mean, just basic questions.
And I'm not saying I'm an
expert in this by any stretch.
But just asking these simple questions.
People that are screaming about it
suddenly admit they know nothing about it.
(Scott chuckles)
- I think they trusted
their side too much,
because they've heard it's important.
They hear it on the news all the time.
Well, it must be important.
Do I need to know the details?
All the smart people
just said it's important.
Generals and politicians, senators.
If they're all saying it's important,
and you're stuck in your silo
and that's all you're hearing,
it's reasonable to think it is
without you knowing all the details.
But like you said, you can
uncover that flaw so easily.
- What do you do with the people
once you've uncovered the flaw,
and now they're kinda freaking out?
Because they don't want
that to happen, right?
That's kinda scary.
- Well, I do the method
that you just described.
You do it in question form.
If you do it in a statement
form, it bounces off.
If you do it in question form it's like,
what was it about the climate agreement,
the Paris Climate Agreement,
that you thought was the good part?
What was the part that was
really gonna make a difference?
How would that affect China
versus how it'd affect the United States?
What would it do to employment?
What would it do to our economy?
So I just ask the questions
and let people talk themselves out of it.
You could affect people's
confidence in the short term,
and then they have to go back
and re-engineer their thoughts.
And sometimes they might change.
- Sometimes.
- Not always, definitely not always.
You'll appreciate this.
A couple weeks ago I was having a debate.
I was having conversation
with an old friend
about the trans issue.
And I said I'm completely
fine with trans people.
Obviously I want everyone
to be treated equally,
and with the same laws, and with respect,
and all of those things.
I said, all I'm saying is
that we can't say that
biology doesn't exist,
that there's a difference
between male and female.
That's all I said.
And he said to me,
"Dave, you're not thinking
with quantum physics."
(Scott chuckling)
And I said, "Could you
tell me a little bit
"about how quantum physics
is related to this?"
And he goes, "Now you're
just trying to get me."
(Scott laughing)
And I thought that is just
the perfect example of all of this.
He just had this idea that quantum physics
has something to do,
if I could just think in some other realm,
then somehow biology of this world,
but actually have nothing to do anything.
And when I asked him about it,
he didn't know anything about it either.
- You might be the best
debater of all time
because you chased him into
another dimension of reality.
He was like, "Oh, I'm out.
"This reality is not serving me well."
- And then he just disappeared.
He was just a smoke.
- Just go on.
- And that was it.
Stay in your channel.
- Yeah.
The worst advice you could
ever give or ever get
is stick to your day job,
stay in your channel,
stay in your lane.
I hear this all the time,
especially when I
transitioned from cartooning,
and even before that,
when I tried to transition
from my cubicle life to cartooning.
Not a lot of support.
Not a lot of people saw that
that would work out for me.
But if you imagine what
would the world look like
if everybody took that advice.
Well, people making bicycles
would never try to make an airplane,
for one.
Steve Jobs wouldn't be
inventing any companies and computers.
So you're already down the lane, the line,
and people leaving their lane
was all the good stuff.
Now, I also tell people to
build their talent stacks,
I call it.
If you're good at this, or a few things,
leave your lane a little bit
and pick up a few other skills.
You might get embarrassed,
you might get tired,
but boy are you gonna be happy
when you've got combined skills
that are practically a superpower.
- Is that another one of
those things where it just
depends a little bit
about how you're wired?
Like some people are
just all in on one thing
and that is how they
can operate their best?
And some people are a little
more designed that they can
maybe change careers more easily,
or just learn what their stack
is a little bit more easily,
and some people just can't do it?
Or are you saying that's
always your job to overcome it?
- There's certainly a personal difference.
There are some people who just wanna stay
doing what they're doing,
and do the best they can.
And if you're Tiger Woods,
that's a great idea.
Tiger Woods doesn't also
need to know accounting.
Well, except
maybe it would help him.
Somebody else is managing his
money and that's never safe.
You can usually tell if
you're in that situation.
Yeah, I need to just run on
this horse as long as I can.
But for most of us, in
just ordinary life...
I can only be a high-end cartoonist
because I assembled a
bunch of pretty good skills
that anybody could have done.
I draw like a, you know, a
drunken monkey, I like to say.
But it got better over time.
I got better tools,
figured out how to do it.
I didn't have any
experience writing humor,
but I figured it out over time.
And I had some business experience,
so I had a canvas to write on.
I'm a perfect example of
a bunch of mediocre skills
that just work pretty well together.
- I wanna back up to
something we started with here
about your career,
because it does fit "Loser Think".
The idea that a guy who, I'm guessing,
you were probably decent
at both of your day jobs
when they told you...
Halfway decent?
Probably not totally in
dereliction of your duties.
Fair to say?
- I showed up on time.
- Okay, you showed up on time.
So you were probably pretty
decent at what you did.
The idea that they said, "Okay, well,"
at two different jobs,
"Diversity, you're in effect
a straight white male,
"You're running out of room here,"
that strikes me as the worst
sort of loser think of the day.
Like people have tricked everybody
into thinking that that diversity matters.
- You know, I surprise people
when I tell them that I'm not...
I don't have a feeling about those times
that you would expect.
I don't feel like society made a mistake.
Because sometimes you
need to use a hammer,
and sometimes you need to use a scalpel,
and you have to know the difference.
In those days when there was
literally just no diversity
in senior management of two
major companies in the Bay Area,
for the newspaper to get on them about it,
I think that's how it happened,
the newspaper got on them,
perfectly appropriate.
And for them to say, "Look,
"this is a sledgehammer situation,
"and today you're the nail."
I remember thinking of it as like,
that's actually a pretty
good societal goal.
And in fact we're much
closer to that reality,
far better diversity.
I think we're better off.
I think it was good.
I just happened to be on the wrong side
of the sledgehammer at that.
So, while it was bad for me,
I don't have an activist opinion
that it shouldn't have happened
because I think it got
us to a better place.
- That's interesting,
but do you think that
part of the problem is that
we take a sledgehammer to everything now?
I don't fully agree with the premise there
because I just think those
things are bad no matter what.
It's just too against the
individual for my personal taste.
But I'll go with you.
Do you think that the problem now
is that so much has changed...
We have diversity pretty much everywhere.
In many ways it benefits you.
And I'm not talking about
diversity of thought.
I'm talking about diversity
of your color and gender
and the rest of it.
But we're still always hitting everything
with a sledgehammer now,
and we don't go in with
the sort of softer tools.
- I'm very much...
I guess my feeling is that
if you've got slavery, you
need your biggest weapon,
the Civil War.
If you've got no civil rights
then you need the civil right movement
and march in the streets.
It's smaller than the nuclear weapon.
And I think we've gotten to the point
where you're talking about
things like institutional racism.
In which case, my preference
is to teach strategy.
Because there does exist
some amount of bias, et cetera,
that will affect some amount of people.
But we now live in a world
where everybody can find a place
where the bias works for them. (chuckles)
There's no Fortune 500
company who doesn't wanna hire
a qualified woman, black
person, gay, LGBTQ, you name it.
They all want them.
If you walk in the door
and you've got the right
degree, right experience,
and you say, "And also," you got a job.
So if you're not teaching strategy
instead of worrying about this
one place you can't get a job,
leave there.
- How do you move, then?
If you've succeeded using the hammer,
it's hard to give up that hammer, right?
- Well, in the political terms,
going big is always good.
You wanna be AOC if you're
gonna be the new politician.
It's like, "What's the
biggest thing I can say
"to set everybody's hair on fire?
"And then if I need to back up..."
- The world's ending in
12 years, don't forget it.
- That's pretty good.
Persuasion wise, pretty good.
And then you shrink it
back as you need it.
Try not to...
Try not to confuse the
hyperbole and the politics
with what's the right tool.
- Right.
Do you think AOC is just
some other version of Trump,
some reverse version of Trump,
just using those same things?
- She is the real deal.
I identified her early on.
People who have similar backgrounds,
Mike Cernovich, for example,
almost identically, the same time,
we just said, "Uh-oh,
watch out for this one."
This was before she was AOC.
She didn't even have the AOC name yet.
And sure enough, she was like a rocket
and everybody could see it.
I believe her backstory
is that she was selected
in almost an American Idol fashion.
- Yeah. If people don't know,
there are YouTube videos
that people can check this out.
They basically picked her
because she ticked off all the boxes.
- So out of all the candidates
she was the strongest one,
so we should not be surprised
that she performs better
than a random person.
- As a guy, though, that likes,
or at the very least understands
Trump's use of persuasion
and go big, scale back,
now watching AOC do it,
and I'm guessing you probably agree
with many less of her policies,
are you worried that that's
all politics will become?
Or has the ship already sailed?
Is that just where we are now? I guess so.
- Well, first of all, I would say
she uses hyperbole the same way Trump did.
When Trump was running for president
and he was talking about
rounding up 14 million illegals
I just said, "That's not
gonna happen." (chuckles)
So I never really took that seriously.
When she says we're gonna die in 12 years,
I don't really take that seriously.
But are they persuading
in the right direction?
Is it good to have tight border security
that you can decide to open
it up as much as you need
or close it when you need to?
Yes, that would just be a good system.
No matter how many people
you decide to let in...
- That's where the conversation is.
- That's a separate question.
Similar with AOC, she's got
an interest in climate change.
I think the scientists have made a case
that CO2 warms things.
I know some people watching
this will disagree.
But most of the scientists say that.
Now, there's certainly
questions about the predictions
and what's gonna happen in the future,
and I would differ there.
But she is moving people in a way
that they weren't moved before.
It probably is an issue
worthy of movement.
Some of the crazy things,
I think she would have to pull back
if she were a national
candidate, and I think she would.
- But is there just a general danger,
we don't have to make this
about her specifically,
that if politics just
becomes people throwing out
just every theory without
really knowing anything behind it...
So I guess I can't make
that not really about her
because I just don't
think she's that bright.
I just don't.
I think she's being...
They selected her, and now I
think she's being manipulated,
and they took a sort of pretty girl
who just likes getting up
there and saying anything.
And that that strikes me
as actually dangerous.
- First of all, I completely disagree
on her intelligence and capability.
- Well, no, I'm not saying
her capability's not good.
I think she's playing a role.
So the capability is there.
I think the actual intelligence behind it,
I don't think, is that great.
I think maybe we're talking about
a different type of intelligence here.
- Certainly she has the
political intelligence.
She has the psychological intelligence.
Social intelligence.
And she obviously knows
more than most people
about the topics because of her job.
But I would say
that she's a productive
part of the conversation.
Because you need somebody that strong
on these big issues like climate change
so that you know, you know,
you're getting a good back and forth,
and then meet somewhere
in the sensible middle.
So I think she's a productive
part of the conversation,
even when I don't agree with her.
- All right, let's shift.
- Let me give you a test.
- Yes.
- Here's a test.
- Okay.
- A very simple test to find
out if she's smart or not.
The answer to climate change,
even if you don't think it's a problem,
is generation for nuclear, or
at least being pro-nuclear.
If you see her never come out
in favor of nuclear as part of--
- Ah, I like where you're going with this.
- As part of the solution,
then she has abandoned reason.
Because even the people
on her side, Corey Booker,
there's several people
running for president.
- Most of them are not, thought, right?
Most of them are not.
- It's half and half, or something.
I think three I know, I can't
remember, but maybe Yang.
But some of the smartest people--
- Yeah, I think Yang is four.
I think.
We should confirm that.
- I believe so.
But some of the smartest people
who are running as Democrats
are already there, and really,
that will tell you.
Is she just playing it for effect
or does she want to solve the problem?
- That's an interesting take.
I guess we'll see in the
next couple months, or...
Well, I guess we ultimately find out
depending on where
Bernie falls against it,
but I'm pretty sure Bernie's
against most nuclear, right?
- Bernie's against.
- But she's now a Bernie surrogate,
so maybe she's not as smart as you think.
- I understand she started with Bernie,
and she's probably
mostly influenced by him.
And Bernie, by the way,
I have so much respect for Bernie
while hating his policies.
Man, that guy's a force of nature.
He really changed the conversation.
I don't want it to go
where he wants it to go,
but I love the fact that
he's gonna introduce this body of thought.
- All right, all this sensible talk aside,
let's shift, for these last few minutes,
into the simulation.
I see this conversation
happening a little bit
here and there, and on some
other podcasts and things.
I don't know that we've
really ever talked about it
on this show before.
What do you mean, the world
could be a simulation?
What is all this crazy talk?
- Let me say, first of all,
that smart people also agree with this.
Elon Musk, for example,
has a similar view.
This comes from Nick Bostrom, a physicist.
So serious people.
And in fact, in Silicon
Valley, near where I am,
it's very common for people
to believe this is true,
but you don't talk about it too much.
And you're gonna find out why.
- Probably dinner parties, yeah.
- You'll find out why
people don't talk about it.
The idea is that we,
our current world is approaching a place
where we could create
a software simulation
of little creatures in a simulated world
that are just software
who would act and believe,
if you could use that
word, that they're real.
Now, maybe we're not quite there,
but you could certainly imagine,
in your lifetime, we'll be there, easily.
Maybe 10 years, 20 years.
The thinking is that if it ever happens,
by any civilization, it
will happen lots of times.
And if it's such a good simulation
the creatures in the simulation
will someday create their own simulation.
Now, what would you look for
to find out if we're a software simulation
who thinks we're real,
or an original species?
Well, here are some of the
things you'd do if it's software.
First thing you'd do is
you would not create all of the history.
You would create it on demand.
For example, if we
discovered a new planet,
that would never be
written until we see it.
Now, in physics, can we
show that an observation
causes a wave to collapse?
I don't know what I'm talking
about right now, by the way.
(Dave laughing)
I hope nobody's watching this
because when I get into
physics it gets all--
- Yeah, yeah.
You had me til wave collapse.
- But it's generally true
that you need a subjective,
or a machine, observation of something.
- Pause for one second.
You have a little spit over here.
Let's just...
Yeah, okay.
All right.
Jump from wave collapse.
- The idea is that, even in physics,
we know that you need an observer,
or a machine observer, I think,
to collapse reality.
In other words, things don't
exist except in probability,
on the quantum level,
as if I know what I'm
talking about here, again,
until somebody observes them.
So that's exactly how
you would build software.
It doesn't exist until you see it.
You would also say, all right,
you little software
people can't get outside
the reality that we defined.
Because if you could, you
could see what you're in.
Can you get to the edge of the universe?
You can't.
- You'll never get there.
- Because speed of light will
keep you from ever doing it.
So you see all of these coincidences
that are exactly compatible
with how a software programmer
would program a world.
Then you look at the odds.
The odds of being an original
when there will be so many copies,
one in a trillion, one in a million?
We don't know.
Maybe it's one in three.
But the odds are certainly
much favoring the simulation
and not that we're an original species.
- So basically that's
the plot of "The Matrix".
If we had to whittle
this into something here.
That we're sort of the batteries
for this digital thing.
- In "The Matrix" they're real people,
and they're also a simulation,
and they're sort of coexisting.
In this, we're just a simulation.
- Would it matter?
You know what I mean?
Let's say we found out
right now, we're in it.
Let's say we became self-aware
within the simulation.
Well, we're still in the
simulation no matter what.
I guess that could alter
how we would deal with
the simulations we would
create going forward.
- Let me ask you this.
And this is just for fun.
Don't anybody take this too seriously.
One of the things you might imagine
is if somebody realized
they're in a simulation,
that they could hack it.
Who believes in the simulation?
Elon Musk.
How's he doing?
(chuckling)
- Ah, I see what you're saying here.
- He's sending a rocket
to Mars, for God's sakes.
- He put a Tesla in space
just because he could.
- How am I doing?
Dilbert worked out okay.
I've got the best book
that's ever been written,
according to me.
Things are going really well with me.
So look for people who
believe in the simulation
and then say to yourself,
"How's it going?"
And you're gonna find a pattern
that will blow your brain out.
- So you're saying whether I
believe in the simulation or not,
I probably should just try to
believe in it a little bit more.
- The people who--
You're saying if this is a simulation,
that if I believe it's a simulation
this video will be monetized.
I think that's what you're saying.
- Let's concentrate really hard.
Monetize, monetize.
Yes, I believe that you will find a way
to vast monetization
if you accept, accept,
pray with me, the simulation.
- That, Scott Adams, is how you
end an interview on YouTube.
You guys can follow Scott
@ScottAdamsSays on the Twitter,
whether this is a simulation or not.
And don't forget to share this
video, and all our videos,
with friends, family, and foes.
You could just click
the little share thing
right down there.
Thanks, everybody.
If you're looking for more honest
and thoughtful
conversations about politics
instead of nonstop yelling,
check out our politics playlist.
And if you wanna watch full interviews
on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode playlist
all right over here.
And to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.